Karen if you read science fiction you
might think that humans in the future
will be slender short ball with big
heads and big eyes that's sort of the
stereotype that you get from the comic
books however you have to realize that
as far as gross evolutionary pressure is
concerned there is none anymore on the
human race for example in the old days
when we lived in the forests there were
enormous selection pressures placed on
us to develop a large brain to
understand how to use tools to run to be
able to navigate to survive in the
forests enormous pressures on us because
if you were not fit to live in the
forest you died and so your genes are
not here today but how much evolutionary
pressure is being placed on us today
well first of all there are no more
Australia's Australia is a continent
that broke off from the other continents
and it evolved very rapidly because it
diverged from the rest of the
evolutionary tree there are no more
Australia's anymore in this sense we
have jet airplanes you can jet airplane
you can go it pretty much anywhere on
the planet Earth meet people have
children and your genes are now spread
throughout the planet Earth we no longer
have any isolated pockets like Australia
which would accelerate human evolution
now evolution is still taking place it
takes place every time two people mate
it takes place inside our bodies in our
immune systems in our body chemistry
evolution is still taking place but
gross evolution that is evolution that
will give us big brains big eyes bald
heads and little bodies that kind of
gross evolution is pretty much gone now
that doesn't mean that we can't have
genetic engineering that's many decades
away at the present time
we can only manipulate perhaps one gene
at a time it is a very painful process
we cannot for example create a pig with
wings that would require thousands of
genes being manipulated and we simply
don't have that technology we only
manipulate one gene at a time so we are
I think
many many many decades away from being
able to actually influence human
evolution so in other words chances are
decades from now will look pretty much
the same